[Music]
sylvia is with us in los angeles hi
sylvia welcome to the ramsey show
oh my god hello mr ramsay um
i have a question i did stupid on
steroids
we did we didn't purchase the car
in june please don't get mad 60 000.
and um we gave of that
fifty five hundred was the sales tax and
six thousand dollars down
and we're looking into like um we tried
to
send it give it back to the dealer they
wouldn't take it and we went to carmax
and we're looking into losing like
another um
two thousand dollars and i don't know if
if it's okay
and right now my husband just got on
disability
again because of this back so we're just
on the unsure
i feel stupid losing that money but then
i see stupid all over
around the car when i see the stupid
purchase we did
[Music]
what do we do what do i do yeah what's
your what's your household income
sweetie
120 that's good news okay
yes yeah um yeah run it back over at
carmax and give them two thousand
dollars and get out of it
yes okay thank you does that feel free
you feel free now yes it does
it does because i keep back and forth
back every time you look at it you can't
catch
your breath yes i
i even drive it like oh my god all
scared and
just stupid just stupid all around you
don't want stupids looking at you in the
driveway every day that's gonna be a
long life
so yeah you need you need to get rid of
this you need to get rid of this thing
you get rid of it quickly while
while you still can while the while the
getting is good do you guys have another
car
okay yes um he my husband has a truck
it's paid off it's worth 20
but you know we need two cars you know
l.a
yeah we just need the two cars and i did
have a car
it was reliable you have any money
yes we do how much money do you have
we have um 25 000. okay good take it
take ten thousand go buy you a car
that's reliable that you need just to
get around with
you gotta then you got two paid for cars
and you make 120 000
a year and then you clean up whatever
other debt you've got you put your
emergency fund back back in place
and um you're going to be fine so george
the question now
we have to ask you sylvia what allowed
you guys to do this and what's going to
keep you from doing it again
i think we were always
going back and forth back and forth of
getting a car
and in my mind i i thought like probably
will pay it off in a year you know that
year gap
but then i guess when i we went to the
store or the dealer it was like
i don't i don't even know what to say
dave
it was just stupid and i knew it listen
i'm not picking on you but here i'm not
picking on you but here's the trick
i've done a lot of stupid stuff in my
life
my goal is to figure out when i did
stupid stuff
why i did that so that i never do it
again
that's why i'm asking you this not to
shame you i'm just saying
yeah you know you guys need to sit down
and talk about and go are we really
committed to
living our life without payments what's
going to protect us what's
going to be our little personal behavior
insurance policy
to keep us from doing this again yeah
and sylvia i want you to check other
places the market's so hot right now you
can check carvana check out all of the
room all these websites and see if you
can get
a better deal on this but dave's right
and based on our parameters
you can't have your 50 of things with
wheels and motors of
of your household income tied up in this
stuff so you guys got too much car but
you can get out of this thing pretty
quick and never
do it again yeah just because there's
just you know you're just over and over
and over
i wish i hadn't done it i wish i'd known
so figure out why you did it never do it
again
so that you never have this kind of a
feeling in your stomach again it's
called regret